what's up guys
bang bang it is lunch money time well
while she's trying to get rich wrestlers
trying to get a lunch money right
paulina's laughing because this is take
two
because i said something inappropriate
on take one inappropriate joke and this
is a kids show it's all right
it was a funny joke the parents would
have laughed but guess what now you
don't get to hear it because
she ruined the party but i'm here she's
here it's awesome look at her michael
jackson sleeves for new year's joke was
about michael jackson you can guess for
yourself what it was look at my sleeves
these are my new year's sleeves like i
said it was a good joke
don't forget that block fly is now a
sponsor of lunch money
block buys got three products you can
buy and sell crypto on the crypto
exchange
you can deposit crypto and take out a us
dollar loan against your crypto
collateral
or you can use my favorite product which
is their interest bearing account
you put in crypto or digital dollars and
they just be
paying you month after month after month
after month give me that interest go get
a block five account block fight.com
pomp now i'm laughing because i'm funny
as hell and you don't like my jokes but
they were funny
it's alright i might leave it in the
comment later let's go because kids
ain't reading the comments
let's go what do we got so
bitcoin so
i was rudely awoken multiple times over
the weekend
because bitcoin decided to go on a ride
take us
all on a ride to 34 000 but now the
price has gone back down to 31 000.
bitcoin sir what do you think it's just
a little monday discount start off the
year don't worry it's a little buy-in
uh discount you know just letting
letting the boys get in real quick
before
the institutions it's all right no
problem uh
all i must say is i told you i told you
this was gonna happen
i've been telling y'all it's happening
right now i'm gonna tell you what's
happening right now
and when it's done i'm gonna tell you i
told you it was gonna happen
so don't worry this is just like another
day
just another day bitcoiners don't want
to sell their bitcoin
and the institutions want bitcoin but
there's not enough bitcoin for the
institutions
so they have to keep adding adding
higher higher higher prices that they're
willing to pay
to buy the bitcoin but bitcoiners ain't
selling nah
you can't have my bitcoin at 32 000. by
the way you can't have it at 300
000 either but that's a whole nother
story go ahead
can i have it no
okay um roku so hold on
quibby is an advanced we know you just
got another profile customer that's why
she keeps checking her wrist
because people keep signing up for her
services she's like what a new customer
so quibby is an advanced talks to sell
its content catalog to roku
wow roku is killing it man quivi
raised 1.75 billion dollars for a
product
that did not work with their target
demographic because they were not their
target demographic to begin with but
that is a whole other
story never gained traction so quibby
has been trying to sell
and roku uh which sells the most popular
streaming
media player in the us is pushing
aggressively into content with its
own ad-supported app the roku channel
so a deal with quibby would give roku a
roster of exclusive programming
this is the best thing that could have
happened in quibby
maybe they should be kissing the ground
that roku walks on one of my brothers
i'm not gonna say which one because i
don't know if he's comfortable with me
saying it or not but he bought roku
early and then it went on a run like a
500
run or 400 run whatever it is and he
reminds me every day
his portfolio bitcoin's up a lot but
roku's up more
and he's just like you know he's a roku
guy now so whatever
okay by the way i think that they should
sell it and if they do sell
their catalog they'll get enough money
to hopefully prevent uh some sort of
bankruptcy get a little bit of cash back
to investors but obviously investors are
going to have lost majority of the
capital
tesla hit its goal of building a half a
million
cars in 2020 a first for the company the
completed deliveries
to customers what that doesn't make
sense
oh the completed deliveries to customers
fell just short of that same goal as it
delivered 499
550 cars elon musk
and tesla have done a tight rope walk
what they are trying to do is nearly
impossible
nearly impossible create an american car
company that disrupts the car industry
and they're pulling it off and everyone
who thought it was impossible are the
exact people who made the market because
a market needs
believers and detractors and boy were
the detractors loud
obnoxious and wrong because guess what
tesla not only has survived some may
even argue it's thriving
they thought that their goals were
ridiculous they were outrageous they
were unattainable
but they're hitting some so maybe
actually the detractors shouldn't be so
obnoxious
and they should just realize they're
wrong fun fact
what tesla stock rise over the last 18
months has made it
the most valuable automaker in the whole
wide world
just wait till the aliens come they got
if you right now had to buy one car
company that was going to be the best
performer over the next 20 years
would you buy ford or would you buy
tesla
i mean that's what's going on well i
don't mind foreign
okay you go by ford oh compare
look at tesla i own no public stocks
other than gbtc
so i really don't care who wins this but
it's pretty obvious for a long time
never bet against innovation you know
what else you shouldn't bet against
home prices in the midwest
hold on home prices are rising across
the nation
but the covid pandemic is turning the
usual geographic trends on their heads
home values have historically risen most
sharply in large cities on the coasts
where supply is leaner and demand is
stronger that is no longer the case
smaller metropolitan markets like
pittsburgh cleveland cincinnati
indianapolis kansas city
boise idaho austin texas
and memphis home prices are going to
keep rising
cheap capital crazy cheap capital
available in the market
you need people moving out of big cities
they're tired they have killed new york
city
new york city this is atrocious
literally what they've done to this city
is absurd i literally sound like an old
cranky man that's what i sound like
now that we can have a real conversation
let me tell you guys the michael jackson
joke that i said at the beginning
i thought it was rant time i was ready
no i look i'm just saying
you're gonna run people out of cities
that's fine that's what's happening so
of course home prices keep going up
there's also a shortage of homes
available in the us we're producing
about 225 000 less homes than we need
for population growth go ahead but do
you think that i mean once
the big cities come back and hopefully
coronavirus
goes far far away could we see people
coming back
sure of course some people will come
back i saw somebody say on twitter i
thought it was really great they're like
oh
oh no millennials are discovering
mcmansions
they realize they don't have to live in
a shoebox in san francisco or la or new
york
they could actually go get a big house
for the same price is it crazy
millennials are now adults with children
and like marriages and houses and
mortgages
speak for yourself crazy right i'm still
a kid at heart
i'm not gonna say it i have warned him
about
calling national kids or ice cream day
she told me i'm not allowed to do it
anymore
just chill for a little bit now that
people are gonna hate me they think i'm
no fun
i am all the fun guys i am so much fun
nobody's had more fun do your job
i'm having all the fun okay so
um so boston dynamics
is this cool robot company where you've
seen
one robot dog open the door for its
robot
dog friend so that's cool but now
but now robots are dancing
the robots are going to come take all
your jobs hold on let's talk about the
dancing
so well they're they're able to dance
and mostly all can't dance so already
the robots are better than you they're
more athletic than you
robots don't freak me out as much as
humanoids do like the ones that are like
you know they they mimic the human um
gestures and movements like those are
the ones that freak me out
there is a arms race between robots
gaining
arms gaining human capabilities
and humans gaining robot capabilities
and that arms race is going to play out
over the next 20 to 40 years
we are going to make our robots as
humanlike as possible and we are also
going to start supplementing
our humans with technology and machines
to make them as robot-like as possible
and the race is on i don't like humans
chances
i think we're gonna lose but that's okay
so are we gonna have ai overlords
i'm gonna be dead i don't care what
happened wait guys
um one of the best talks i've ever seen
on ai
in our robot overlords is tim urban just
google tim
urban ai on youtube 100
recommend you can't do that signal
people think oh shoot shoot
oh no is that bad too yeah well of
course because everything's been
politicized
yay all right everything's been
politicized so we have one
ask lunch money question guys if you
have questions for us do hashtag
ask lm in the comments when you go
looking for the michael jackson joke you
can put hashtag 13
hails asks a really good question hi
pomp and paulina i love you guys in your
show i've learned a lot so far
my question is where do you suggest the
normal person should go
in order to upgrade their circle of
friends like make actual new friends not
surface level bs because they say you
become the company you keep and it's
essential
to let to keep leveling up in life yes
that is so true
okay so here's one thing i think i heard
shonda rhimes said
say this and it really stuck with me
basically
um you uh uh god how did you put it
anthony what are you doing basically um
take take who you want to become and
enter what was it enter groups
where your desired behavior is the
normal behavior
so join a group where you want to let's
say you want to learn about business
find an online group there are so many
where you can join and your desired
behavior to
be better at investing learn more about
entrepreneurship is the normal behavior
in that group and you can actually
entertain ideas and brainstorm new
things
versus talking to your friends who care
not at all about entrepreneurship
and you have to convince them why it's
an interesting thing to talk about
so focus on finding one
everyone always wants to go find 100 new
friends or
20 new friends i want to go upgrade all
my friend group don't do that
just find one find one person that
you're like this is intellectually a
person that
uh i want to learn from i want to spend
time with they're going to make me
better yada yada whatever
uh you can do it online that's probably
the easiest way is literally go find
people on the internet that you think
are uh valuable or that meet those
requirements and then start talking to
them there
and then you can bring it into the real
world later you can meet up for a coffee
or a beer
or uh you can walk with your mask on and
hide from the virus
um that only comes out after 10 o'clock
and so uh
you could do all of that um but i think
that uh
just starting with one rather than a
bunch of people um
is key now i i have to go do something
and paulina has to go do something uh so
we have to end the show but before we do
i have one story to tell you guys
on new year's eve uh we were with some
friends and we went to dinner but it
wasn't like a really serious dinner but
it wasn't like a like a not serious
dinner
so i decided to wear my nice black
hoodie there were people in suits and
ties in there there was there was
somebody in a suit and a tie and he
looked at me weird but that's fine i
looked at him weird too
and so i wore my nice black hoodie and
planet was like you're not even dressed
up and i was like this is my nice one
she goes that's not that nice and i said
oh yeah
and then i tied my strings in a bow tie
and i said look around the room
there's nobody else here with a bow tie
on and she just looked at me rolled her
eyes and then we had a great dinner it
was amazing so just so we all know
sometimes you have to think outside the
box and you have to come up with
the best outfit possible
good job nice all right guys see you
tomorrow
bang bang hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five so go check them
out there's a link in the description
that you can click on
i'm an investor a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block five is my second favorite thing
in the world behind paulina they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to eight point six percent
interest on an interest bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find
up to 8.6 interest on a deposit in an
interest bearing account
go do your own research there's risk
associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends